as you can probably see vehicles are
starting to move a bit quicker now into
the port of Dover which is just in front
of me here but there's still a long line
of cars wanting to go through here this
is the top end of the queue the queue
stretches all the way back into town out
the other side a couple of a couple of
miles but things as I say are starting
to move a bit quicker a bit more
smoothly here but it's simply just a lot
of people wanting to get across the
channel at the start of this bank
holiday weekend the start of the half
term holiday of course now initially
passengers were told to allow up to two
hours to get through the Border checks
here because of I.T issues on the French
border controls though issues those
issues have now been resolved but the
port of Dover is still warning people of
a 45 minute wait to get through simply
because things now take time here the
brexit means extra border checks simply
take longer around 90 seconds for cars
up to 15 minutes for coaches and when
there's lots of vehicles here it is a
bit of a a pinch Point here
and speaking to passengers in their cars
well um earlier people seemed to quite
resigned to the fact that if you come to
Dover there are delays but even so
um still some High Spirits as people
head off on their holidays
uh about an hour and 15 minutes hour and
15. how does that compare to normal I've
never experienced these problems at
Dover before
you ever so yeah we've not identity I
don't do that have you have you made
your Ferry oh no it's not as bad as it
seems is it we've been delayed of an
hour I've only double the amount of time
we needed to get you and have still
missed our chicken for our fairy so not
quite sure what we're going to do next
but we'll just have to wait and see
there's a nationwide problem with
e-gates those are the electronic Gates
that people can use to have their
passports checked automatically when
they come into the country
um so across the country uh they are not
working today the system's down and that
means passports are having to be checked
manually by border force staff uh the
problems began last night they still
haven't been fixed the home office has
said they're trying to fix resolve the
issues as soon as possible but it's
meant long queues for people arriving in
the country reports of up to of Weights
of up to four hours to get through
through the airport on arrival clearly
not how you want to be starting the bank
holiday weekend and this follows
problems getting out of the country uh
by by airplane the last two days British
Airways canceling 175 flights in total
um mostly short haul from Heathrow down
affected 20 000 passengers the knock on
impact is still being felt today so the
problems with departures problems with
arrivals ports and airports affected
clearly not the best way to start a bank
holiday weekend